[music]
Are you
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey
darling.
Happy.
[music]
Oh.
The lecture tonight is titled the man
behind the mask because we want to know
who the man behind the scenes is that
is going to play a major role in the
events culminating in the very end
events before the coming of Christ. And
the book of Daniel gives us a lot of
information on this issue. And in fact,
the book of Daniel, as we have said
before, forms the template for the book
of Revelation.
And the prophecy that we will be going
through tonight is a prophecy that acts
as a key for the book of Revelation.
Again, I'd like to remind you of our
little dictionary of prophetic terms.
White linen, righteousness.
Trumpet wind is a symbol of war. Trumpet
can also be a symbol of judgment.
Prostitution is idolatry,
being unfaithful to God.
Water or sea equals nations. Revelation
17:5. A woman, you will remember, is a
church, Zion. God's people. Tonight
we're going to deal with beasts and
kingdoms and we'll see the definitions
there for ourselves and horns and kings
and kingdoms. We'll see those
definitions for ourselves as well. And
the rock is Jesus. There are many many
texts um indicating that. So let us have
a look at this vision tonight of Daniel
chapter 7. It's one of the most
thunderous visions in the Bible. It's
really staggering and it's actually
quite scary.
In the first year of Balshasa, king of
Babylon, so this is right towards the
end of the Babylonian
um kingdom, Daniel had a dream. So now
it's not the king who has a dream, but
Daniel who has a dream. And obviously
Daniel is going to get more detail than
the king had in his previous vision
which was the sort of the ABC of
prophecy. He had a dream and a vision of
his head upon his bed and then he wrote
the dream and told the sum of the
matters. So he's going to explain it. We
don't have to guess about this issue.
Daniel 7:es 2 and 3. And I saw in my
vision by night and behold the four
winds.
What was that?
War
of heaven strove upon the great sea. So
there was war among the nations.
And four great beasts kingdoms came up
from the sea diverse from one another.
They were different to each other.
Daniel 7:es 2 and three. So now let's
just make sure that we have this right.
Bible prophecy symbols. Remember the sea
is people, nations, multitudes.
Revelation 17:15. Wind we said was war.
Jeremiah 49:36 and 37. Beasts are
kingdoms. Daniel 7:17.
Let's read those texts to make
absolutely sure. Revelation 17:15, the
waters which thou sourest are peoples
and multitudes and nations and tongues.
So there's the first symbol. Let's go to
Jeremiah and see what we can see here.
49:36. And upon Elam will I bring the
four winds from the four quarters of
heaven, and will scatter them towards
all those winds, and there shall be no
nation whether the outcasts of Elam
shall not come. Verse 37, for I will
cause Elam to be dismayed before their
enemies. Now we call that Hebrew
parallelism.
Something is explained in one way and
then repeated in another way and in that
way the symbols are explained. They are
self-explanatory then. So the four winds
which scatter Elim mean that Elim will
be dismayed before their enemies. There
will be wars and before them that seek
their life and I will bring evil upon
them even my fierce anger, says the
Lord. I will send the sword war after
them till I have consumed them. So there
you have the parallelism. So you can see
that the sea equals the nations and the
wind equals the wars. Daniel 7:17, the
four great beasts are four computers in
Brussels.
>> Oh no, it doesn't say that at all. It
says the four great beasts are four
kingdoms that will arise from the earth.
So four kingdoms are going to come and
they're described as beasts.
17:23
the fourth beast shall be the fourth
kingdom upon the earth. So that's the
biblical definition. We cannot make it
anything other than what the Bible says
it's going to be. So the four beasts or
four kingdoms that shall arise upon the
earth. And now we can look at the
kingdoms and see where we are going. The
first was like a lion and had eagle's
wings. I beheld till the wings thereof
were plucked and it was lifted up from
the earth and made to stand upon the
feet as a man and a man's heart was
given to it. Daniel 7 verse4
now the first kingdom that we had in
Daniel chapter 2 the head of gold Daniel
identified it as what? Babylon. The
first beast we see here is the lion with
eagle's wings, which by the way was the
symbol, one of the symbols of Babylon.
And what is fascinating here is that
this beast was made to stand upon the
feet as a man and a man's heart was
given to it. This is a system, a kingdom
that exalts
the human above the divine.
This is the ultimate apostasy against
God, putting man in the place where God
should be. And we will see as we
continue in this series that end time
events also culminate in this very
matter. Man being placed where the
divine should be. So Bob L as I've
already said Babel Bob is gate L is God
portal to God another way to God another
way other than the prescribed way which
we find in the Bible. So here is this
power that will arise and it stands for
Babylon. It parallels the head of gold
605 to 539 BC.
Let's have a look at Jeremiah for the
symbolism. Jeremiah 4:7. A lion has come
out of his lair. A destroyer of nations
has set out. He has left his place to
lay waste your land. The prophet is
speaking to Israel, Jerusalem. Your
towns will lie in ruins without
inhabitants. And the lion he was
referring to was the kingdom of
Nebuchadnezzar. Babylon was going to
come. And Jeremiah applies the symbol of
the lion to Babylon. So the first
kingdom is Babylon. Here's a symbol that
was used in Babylon. You can see the
lion with the eagle's wings. Part of
that symbolism.
Here's another relief.
And there again, you see the lions with
the eagle's wings, symbols of Babylon.
So archaeology confirms that that was
the symbolism that was used. So we do
not have to guess at what was to
transpire. The Bible gives us a good
start. Daniel chapter 2 started with
Babylon. Daniel chapter 7 starts with
Babylon. And suddenly another
beast replaced that with another word
kingdom.
A second like a bear. It was raised up
on one side and had three ribs in its
mouth
between its teeth. And they said thus to
it, "Arise, devour much flesh." Daniel
7:5. So this beast is going to come and
it's going to devour the flesh of the
previous one. It's going to make war and
replace it. and it had three ribs and
one side was higher than the other. Now
what was the next kingdom in Daniel
chapter 2?
It was Meo Persia. Now we have a little
bit more detail here. The Mes and the
Persians weren't equally yolked. At
first the Mes were the prominent one and
was raised up on one side. Later on the
Persians rose to be the equivalent and
even higher. So it was not equal in uh
its power. So the next kingdom to come
along would be Meo Persia. Three ribs in
its mouth. There were three major wars
associated with that conquest.
So me Persia represents is the parallel
of the arms of silver and the chest and
they ruled from 539 to 331
BC. And there are the thrusts that they
made. The one into Lydia conquering
these portions of the Babylonian Empire.
The other thrust to Babylon itself and
the third one down into Egypt. And they
basically conquered the entire
Babylonian kingdom with these three
conquests representing the three ribs in
their mouth. Daniel 7:6. After this, I
beheld, and lo, another like a leopard,
which had upon the back of it four wings
as of a fowl. The beast had also four
heads and dominion was given to it.
That's fascinating.
Daniel 7:6, the next kingdom to come
along, of course, was the
Greek kingdom. And here it is described
as a leopard. Remember the animals.
There's a lion, there's a bear, and now
there's a leopard.
and four heads associated with this
beast. How many heads on the first one?
One head. How many heads on the second
one? One head plus four heads.
And uh interesting story. After this I
beheld and lo another like a leopard
which had upon its back of it four wings
of a fowl. The beast also had four heads
and dominion was given to it. So the
next kingdom to come along was Greece
331 to 168 BC. And when Greece was at
the height of its power, Alexander the
Great died after a night of drunken
stuper. He lingered for a while and then
died and the kingdom was divided into
four. the four generals Cassandra,
Lissimacus, Tommy and Seucid Kingdom.
That is the division of the Greek Empire
into four. Fascinating. So there were
four heads. So now we already have a
total of six heads. The lion, the bear
plus the four make six.
After this, Daniel 7:7, I saw in the
night vision, and behold, a fourth
beast, dreadful and terrible,
exceedingly strong.
It had huge iron teeth. Do you remember
the symbol of iron?
Where did we find it?
In Daniel chapter 2, and it was a symbol
of the Roman Empire. Here we have the
same symbolism. It was devouring,
breaking in pieces, and trampling the
residue with its feet. Here's this
mighty empire, politically the most
powerful of the four, and it would
destroy and devour with its feet. And
there's something very interesting about
it. Daniel 7:7,
it was different
from all the beasts that were before it.
And it had 10 horns.
Right?
There are no numbers of heads mentioned
here. So we assume it had one head with
10 horns. So if you count all the heads
of the beasts of Daniel chapter 7, how
many heads do we have? We have seven
heads. Seven heads. Now the beasts that
we will find in the book of Revelation
have seven heads. And the beasts in the
book of revelation with the seven heads
also have all the components of the
beasts that are mentioned here in Daniel
chapter 7. So we must know what each of
these heads represents and what the
philosophies were that were associated
with those time periods.
Now this particular beast was also
different from all the beasts that were
before it and it had 10 horns. Now the
10 horns as we saw in the definitions
would also be kingdoms. Verse 24 says
and the 10 horns out of this kingdom are
10 kings that shall arise.
So out of Rome 10 kingdoms would arise
and another shall rise after them. So
after the 10 had arisen, after Rome had
been divided into 10, another one would
arise
and he
shall be diverse from the first and he
shall subdue three kings. All right,
this is fascinating. So the fourth beast
divides into 10, but it's still
basically that beast. It's still that
beast that divides into 10. And out of
this beast, amongst the division of the
10 comes another power and he is the one
that adds the different flavor. Is that
clear? Is that what the text says? He
shall be diverse, different from the
first. So Rome will be different to the
others because of that beast. And he
will rule for how long? Until the
ancient of days came and judgment was
given to the saints. That's a long long
time. Very long long time. So Rome ruled
from 168 BC to 476
AD. It will divide into 10. How many
toes did the previous
prophecy depict?
10 toes. There we have the 10 again.
Divide into 10. Another will arise after
them. And he will be different. And the
system will remain how long?
Until the ancient of days shall come.
Who? Long time. So we're talking about a
long long time span.
Rome ruled from 168 BC to 476 AD
and then it was divided up. So we have
exactly the same sequence. We have the
lion depicting the head of gold. Then we
have the bear depicting the arms and the
chest of silver. We have this foreheaded
leopard representing the hips of bronze.
And then we have the terrible beast
representing the legs of iron and the 10
toes when it divides into 10. Plus it
will be different because of another
that arises after them. So that's what
we have so far. Daniel 7 verse 19 to 20
and 23.
Then I would know the truth of the
fourth beast, which was diverse,
different from all the others, exceeding
dreadful, whose teeth were of iron and
his nails of brass. Bronze. So there was
an element of bronze in this fourth
beast. Bronze was a very important
component. Now in actual fact the Greek
empire was basically just incorporated
by Rome. Greek philosophy was the very
basis of the Roman Empire. And in fact
when Rome split into the two legs the
one was the Bzantine Empire and the
other one the Western Empire and the
empire was ruled from Constantinople
and that is where Greek philosophy
abounded. Greek philosophy was the the
philosophy of the time. So there's this
element of brass of bronze bronze claws
scratched and we'll find uh these nails
also interestingly uh elsewhere later on
which devoured broken pieces and stamped
the residue with its feet. So he wanted
to know about this terrible fourth
beast. The fourth beast, we are told in
verse 23,
shall be a fourth kingdom upon the
earth, which shall be different from all
the kingdoms, and shall devour how much
of the earth?
>> The whole earth, and shall tread it
down, and break it in pieces. Now, did
Rome
in its original form take over the whole
world? Yes or no?
>> No. No. What about China? What about
Japan? What about the Philippines? What
about Australia? What about uh Southern
Africa? What about the United States?
What about South America? What about
those areas? Did Rome rule over all of
those? Yes or no? Obviously not. But
remember, the prophecy doesn't say Rome
ends. The prophecy says the that Rome is
divided into
10 and that another arises after them
who rules until when?
Until the ancient of days comes.
So the prophecy can still be fulfilled
in that context. Doesn't that make
sense? Okay,
that's very interesting. So here we have
this mighty Roman Empire.
This is what the Bible says. There would
be these kingdoms and 10 horns would
arise. 10 kingdoms. 10 kingdoms
represent the 10 toes. Uh 476
until the second coming of Christ.
These powers would somehow continue and
the little one after him that would
arise later, he would be the different
element and he would rule until the
ancient of days came along. Daniel 2:44,
remember talking about the 10 toes,
which are the equivalent of the 10
horns, says, "And in the days of these
kings
shall the God of heaven set up a kingdom
which shall never be destroyed, and the
kingdom shall not be left to other
people, but it shall break in pieces and
consume all these kingdoms, and it shall
stand forever." So we have a perfect
parallel between Daniel chapter 2 and
Daniel chapter 7.
Now Daniel was wondering about this and
in verse 8 it says I was considering the
horns. So he's looking down the stream
of time and he's looking to where Rome
divides up into 10 components and he's
looking at these 10 kingdoms that arise
out of the Roman Empire.
And there was a another horn,
a little one. Actually, it says from
littleness. It was first small and then
it grew bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger. Coming up, where does it come
up?
Among them. All right. So, this little
horn comes up among the 10. very
important because this little horn is
the man behind the mask and this little
horn comes up amongst the 10. So the 10
kingdoms are there and he arises amongst
them. So what type of power is this?
This is a European power because the 10
horns arose out of the western Roman
Empire. So, can we look for this little
horn in the Middle East, for example?
Yes or no? No. Can we look for this
little horn in the United States of
America, for example?
No. Where do we have to look for him?
There where he's supposed to arise. He
has to come up among the 10. He cames
comes up among the 10. And all 10 are
there when he arises.
Notice before whom three of the first
horns were plucked out by the roots. So
because of this power, three of the 10
had to be removed. Does that make sense?
We're going to take three away. And
who's going to take them away? Or as a
consequence of whom will be they be
removed? This power. It's very important
that we get him absolutely spot on
because we don't want to make a mistake.
And there in this horn were the eyes
like the eyes of a man and a mouth
speaking pompous words.
Where did we find this symbolism
earlier? This man symbolism.
Babylon. Remember found it in Babylon.
Here's the same symbolism. In this
power, man will once again lift himself
up above the most high and take the
place of the most high. This is another
babel, another portal to heaven. Man
exalting himself above the divine with
pompous words. He's speaking against
God. All right. So now we have some
history.
He arises
out of the division of the Roman Empire.
Once it is divided into 10, then only
does he make his appearance. Three of
them are bothersome to him. They are
eliminated under his influence and then
he rises up like a mushroom and sets man
above the divine. That's what it says.
That's what it says. And the 10 horns
out of this kingdom are 10 kings that
shall arise and another, there he is,
shall rise after them. Question, does he
arise out of the remnant of the Roman
Empire or out of the remnant of the
Greek Empire?
Roman Empire. Roman Empire. Don't forget
that the stone also struck the feet. It
struck which empire? The Greek or the
Roman Empire? The Roman Empire. So
already if you know this, you should be
able to solve half of the problem of
false prophecy out there in the world
that says that the antichrist will arise
or arose in the past in the time of
Greece. No, no, no. The Bible does not
say that. The Bible says he arises when
once Rome is divided into its
components. That's what the Bible says.
And he rules until the ancient of days
comes. Is he around here now?
Well,
>> must he be here? Sure, he must be here.
Are people waiting for him? Sure. What
for? He's here. We shouldn't have to
wait. We should just be able to say
there is.
That's very interesting.
So he shall be different from the first.
So the flavor of the fourth beast is
made different by whom? By him. Why
different? And he is the one that's
responsible for removing three whole
kingdoms.
Well, you remember the kingdoms, the
Anglo-Saxons, the Franks, the Alammani,
the Lombards, the Arthrots, the Heruli,
the Beagandians, the Visigotss, the
Sivvian, and the Vandals. Those were the
10. But there were some terribly opposed
to this power. Number one, the Heruli
AD493.
Look where they ruled. Look where they
ruled. Now, these people had an
interesting philosophy. And this
philosophy differed
substantially from the philosophy of
this other little horn power. Now,
unfortunately, we have no historic
documents as to what the Heruli
believed. Neither do we have any
historic documents as to what the
Ostrogoths believed. We have a little
bit of what the vandals believe, but
none of their religious documentation.
Why not?
Because it has all been destroyed.
So, we only have information from those
secondhand. Apparently, history tells us
today that these three powers that were
re removed were Aryan in their view. In
other words, that they taught that Jesus
was not God. and therefore had to be
removed. But there is really no evidence
for that whatsoever other than
secondhand information by the very power
that destroyed them.
There's far more interesting evidence
that these powers that were destroyed
actually had a different gospel.
A gospel that was derived from Palestine
and was a much truer reflection of the
biblical than any other. So is it
perhaps possible that they had a
Christianity
derived directly from the original
source and that they therefore had to be
removed? It's a distinct possibility.
There's quite a lot of research that has
been done on it and uh I'm not averse to
that idea at all. So they were destroyed
AD. Now if this creature, this fourth
one, uh, this new power arose amongst
them, then he must have arisen already
before 493.
The next one to go were the Vandals AD
534.
They plagued the Roman Empire and they
subjected large parts of the religious
culture of culture of the Bzantine and
Roman world. They subjected it
ferociously. And so eventually the
Vandals were also destroyed by the
armies of the
Eastern Empire. And then came the
Ostrogoths. They were the last ones. The
Ostrogoths ruled until 538 AD. And they
occupied first this area and later
occupied and controlled the whole of the
ancient Roman capital and surrounding
areas. And the Ostrogoths also had a
gospel derived as we said from ancient
Palestine. So they had to be removed.
They were tolerant of all other
religions, but they were a thorn in the
flesh of the little horn power. And
eventually they were destroyed with the
help amongst others of the Franks up
here who made an alliance with the kings
of Constantinople with the Caesars.
And so in 538 AD, the opposition to the
little horn power disappeared and it
rose like a mushroom. So the Alammani,
the remnant of the 10, you are the
Germans today, the Beanians, the Swiss,
the Franks, the French, the Lombards,
the Italians, the Saxons, the English,
the Suevi, the Portuguese, the
Visigoths, the Spanish and the Heruli,
the Vandals, and the Ostrogoths are
eliminated, totally destroyed. In fact,
these were the only not the only ones
that uh the waged war against. Oh, no,
no, no. The Visigothths for example
probably being very much related to the
Ostrogoths had similar sentiments and
there were many many wars fought and
much subjugation over here uh before
these came in line with the thinking of
the little horned power as well. The
greatest ally of the little horned power
was the Franks who are today the French.
And the first one to adopt this robe
upon himself was Clovis. And Clovis will
go down in history as the man who more
than any other helped the little horn
power to come to fruition.
Daniel 7:9.
I beheld till the thrones were cast
down, and the ancient of days did sit,
whose garment was white as snow, and the
hair of his head like the pure wool, his
throne was like the fiery flame, and his
wheels as burning fire. So Daniel is
watching the events down here on earth,
which all seem to revolve around this
little horn power, and he sees a great
judgment scene taking place in heaven.
Verse 10 says, "The judgment was set and
the books were opened." So here is a
judgment scene.
And I saw in the night vision, "And
behold, one like the son of man come
with a clouds of heaven." That's an
acronym for angels. We'll see that in a
in a later lecture. And came to the
ancient of days. And they brought him
near before him. Verse 13. So this is
not the coming of Christ to this earth.
This is a scene that takes place in
heaven as the little horned power sets
up his domain here on this earth. So the
judgment is ready to sit in the heavenly
realm. And there was given him, this is
the son of man, dominion and glory and a
kingdom that all the people, nations,
and languages should serve him. His
dominion is an everlasting dominion
which shall not pass away and his
kingdom that which shall not be
destroyed. Verse 14. So we have a
contrast over here. On the one hand you
have a kingdom being set up on earth
whose seat and power lies in the little
horn power and on the other hand you
have a judgment taking place where all
power will be given to Christ. So we
have two powers opposed to each other.
Christ, the ultimate victor in the end,
and the antichrist working against each
other. The one setting up a kingdom upon
this earth, the other one setting up the
eternal kingdom that'll never be
destroyed. And the saints of the most
high shall take the kingdom and possess
the kingdom forever, even forever and
ever. Daniel 7:18. Beautiful symbolism.
Very powerful stuff.
Now
let's have a look at Paul's reference to
the man of sin.
In 2 Thessalonians chapter 2:es 1 to10,
Paul describes when this power, this
antichrist power will arise. Now we
beseech you, brethren, by the coming of
our Lord Jesus Christ, and by our
gathering together unto him, that you
not be soon shaken in mind, or be
troubled, neither by spirit, nor by
word, nor by letter as from us, as that
day of Christ is at hand. You see, some
were teaching even in Paul's days that
uh the day of the Lord is at hand.
And some were preaching that Christ was
already ruling. And Paul says, "No, no,
no, no, no. There's first some things
that must happen. So the day of Christ
is not there yet. Let no man deceive you
by any means, for that day, the coming
of the Lord, shall not come except there
come a falling away first." So first the
church goes into apostasy
and that man of sin be revealed the son
of pition.
Only two folks in the Bible are called
son of pition. Only two. The one is the
man of sin and the other one was Judas.
Now, how did Judas betray Jesus?
With a kiss. He betrayed him with a
kiss. You see, Judas pretended to still
be one of them and he betrayed Jesus.
the other one. Do you think he might
also pretend to be one of them and
betray
Jesus with a kiss? Do you think it's
possible on a greater scale? So let no
man deceive you by any means, for that
day the coming of the Lord will not come
except there come a falling away first
apostasy in the church. And that man of
sin be revealed, the son of pedition,
who opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called God or that he's
worshiped, so that he as God siteth in
the temple of God, showing himself that
he is God. So here is a power that
assumes tremendous
presumptuous powers unto itself. In
fact, this power is going to say, "I am
another God on this earth." And
salvation
is through me. But this power is going
to be a subtle power that worked just
like Judas worked. Just like Judas
worked.
And this is the spirit of Antichrist
whereof you have heard that it should
come and even now already is in the
world. 1 John 4:3.
So now let's think about this. If the
spirit of antichrist
was already in the world in the time of
John, if Paul says there will come a
falling away and then this man of sin
will be revealed,
then this man of sin has been with us
all along. So now we've already seen
that he cannot have come out of a Greek
empire because he comes out of the
fourth empire and he also cannot come in
the future sometime
from a tribe in Palestine.
Is that correct?
Would you all agree with me?
>> All right. That is correct. Then the
whole of Christianity
must be lying wrong on this issue
because half of Christianity teaches
that the antichrist came in the past.
His name was Antiocus Epipanas 4 and he
was a Greek king.
Uh the Bible says he come out of the
fourth beast and in fact after the
decline of the fourth beast and the
division into 10.
The other half of Christianity is taught
that the Antichrist will come into the
future after the rapture.
Now, there's a problem because then the
Christian church is not even part of us.
But here he was already in the world
acting already in a clandestine manner
in the early Christian church. So
neither of those two can be right. Paul
continues, "Remember ye not that when I
was yet with you, I told you these
things,
and now you know what withholdeth that
he might be revealed in his time." So
something is holding back this power
from arising, and something is
withholding it. For the mystery of
iniquity doth already work.
So this power, this iniquitous mystery
power is already working in the world in
Paul's time. So this is not a future
power that will only come at the end of
time. No, no, no. It's been here all
along.
Only he who now letth will let until he
be taken out of the way. Or let's read
the the BBE version. There is one who is
keeping back the evil till he is taken
out of the way. So there was some power
holding back so this little horn power
could not arise. And Paul had told them
what it was. Remember I told you these
things. But he doesn't say it here.
And then shall the wicked be revealed
whom the Lord shall consume with the
spirit of his mouth and shall destroy
with the brightness of his coming. So
this power will be revealed when
something holding it back is taken away
or some power holding it back and then
this power will be destroyed at the
second coming of Christ.
Even him whose coming is after the
working of Satan
with all power and signs and lying
wonders.
This is an interesting story. and with
all deceivleness of unrighteousness in
them that perish because they received
not the love of the truth that they
might be saved. Is it possible that this
system will deceive the world into
accepting a form of the gospel which is
based on human values and not on divine
values and on human criteria and not on
divine criteria? Is that possible?
Here we have a point on which Paul we
read in Romanism and the reformation by
Gratan. Paul affirms the existence of
knowledge in the Christian church. So
the early church knew he says what the
hindrance was. The early church tells us
what it did know upon the subject and no
one in these days can be in a position
to contradict its testimony as to what
Paul had by word of mouth only told the
Thessalonians. It is a point on which
ancient tradition alone can have
authority. Modern speculation is
positively impertinent on such a
subject. Today people are saying, well,
what could have been holding it back?
Maybe it's the Holy Spirit holding it
back. Why should the Holy Spirit be
holding it back? There was a power
holding it back. And when that is
removed, the antichrist will arise and
he will remain until the Lord comes. So
what did the early church fathers know?
What did Paul told them? verbally.
What did he told them? But what did he
not write down? Well, let's go to the
early church fathers. Tertullian on the
resurrections, Christian apologists of
200 AD. He says, "He who now hinders
must hinder until he's taken out of the
way. What obstacle is there but the
Roman state? The falling away of which
by being scattered into 10 kingdoms
shall introduce Antichrist."
So that's what the early church fathers
believe that when the Roman state goes,
Antichrist will be revealed.
Is that biblical according to Daniel
chapter 7? Absolutely. When Rome divides
into 10, when Roman state disappears,
Antichrist will be revealed. That's what
the early church fathers believe.
Here's another one. John Christ homaly
2, Thessalonians 2. He was bishop of
Constantinople 390. He says only there
is one that restrainth now until he be
taken out of the way. That is when the
Roman Empire is taken out of the way.
Then he antichrist shall come. Believe
the same thing. Here's another one.
Edward Elliot who writes commentary on
the apocalypse in 1862. He says, "We
have the consenting testimony of the
early fathers from Irenaeus, the
disciple of St. John down to Chrysler
and Jerome to the effect that it was
understood to be the imperial power
ruling and residing at Rome. So it's
actually quite simple. When Rome falls,
the antichrist will come.
While the Caesars held imperial power,
it was impossible for the predicted
antichrist to arise. On the fall of the
Caesars, he would arise. There's another
source. Paul did not identify the
restraining power which they knew to be
Rome for fear of reprisals. Remember the
Christian church was under persecution
by Rome. There's another quote. So Paul
didn't say when Rome falls he'll come.
Because if he had said publicly and
written when Rome falls he will come he
would have been in big trouble and so
would the persecuted church. So the
early church believed that when Rome
falls Antichrist will arise. Daniel 7
says he will arise when Rome is divided
into 10 then he will arise. So that's
the biblical criteria of when antichrist
starts ruling.
We're going to talk now about this
little horn power. We have learned
up until now that he arises when
when Rome is divided. We have learned
that he comes out of this division and
that he arises amongst the 10 horns. And
we have learned that he shall be
different from the first. Daniel 7:4.
And this power will stay with us until
Jesus comes. That means if he arose then
he must be here today. Let's have a look
at the attributes given by Daniel of the
little horn power. Number one, he arises
out of the fourth beast. Daniel 7 verse
7 and 8. Is everybody happy with that?
So he comes out of Rome. That's where he
rises. It's a Roman power.
Number two, he arises amongst the 10
horns. I considered the horns and
beheld, there came up amongst them
another little horn. So he has to arise
in the Western Roman Empire. It is a
European power. It's not any other power
on this earth.
He arises after the T horns. So he
assumes his position of power sometime
after 476
AD. And another shall arise after them.
Verse 24.
He's different from the other horns. He
shall be diverse from the first. Verse
24. That's the fourth criterion.
Here's another criterion. He becomes
more stout than the others, more stout
than his fellows. Verse 20, here's a
power that becomes mightier than any of
the other kingdoms. Do you know what
shouldn't be too difficult
to see what the Bible is saying?
Uncomfortable, yes, but not too
difficult. He uproots three kingdoms
before whom three fell.
verses 20.
He has eyes like a man and spoke great
words against the most high. Verses 8
and verse 25.
So he lifts himself up into the position
where God should be. Number one, he
replaces divine precepts with human
precepts. And he maps out the path to
heaven through the power of man and not
the power of God. This is a serious
serious issue.
And he speaks great things against the
most high. We'll have to look at that.
And then he'll make war against the
saints. He'll wear out the saints. Verse
25. So this power must have been a
persecuting power that fought against
those who said salvation is through the
power of God alone.
And then another criterion, he'll change
times and laws. Verse 25 says he'll
think to change times
and laws. That's fascinating. Now which
times and which laws do you think uh God
would be concerned about? Would God be
concerned about silly little human laws?
No. It must be modification of divine
law and the times must be changing the
times which God had set. For example,
God set the time and it shall be evening
and it shall be morning the first day
and it shall be evening and it shall be
morning the second day. From evening to
evening went the day. That's the first
time. Then there were feasts and
festivals and times that were set. Would
this power change all of that?
Fascinating. That's the ninth criterium
given in the book of Daniel. Daniel is
very precise.
And he will rule. They shall be given
into his hand unto a time, times, and
the dividing of time. time, times, and
half a time. Prophetic years, three and
a half. We'll deal with that.
Fascinating. Verse 25.
And shall devour the whole earth. The
fourth beast which shall be different
shall devour the whole earth. The
different component of it shall devour
the whole earth and shall trample it and
crush it. Does that include the United
States of America? Mhm. Do you think you
are being controlled by someone else? Do
you think you might be being right now
being controlled by someone else? The
mighty USA? Do you think so? What about
the mighty Russia? What about any mighty
nation? What about China? Do you think
they might be controlled right now by
someone else?
And it exists till the end until the
ancient of days came. Verse 22. Now, I'm
not making this up. This is in the book
of Daniel. You can get the book of
Daniel yourselves and you can read it.
And the final criterium, his dominion
will be taken away at the end of time,
but the judgment shall sit and they
shall take away his dominion to consume
and to destroy it unto the end. The
Bible says he shall be destroyed by the
brightness of the Lord's coming.
So no earthly power is going to take his
power away. God himself is going to
intervene. 13 criteria.
There is only one power
in the whole wide world historically and
otherwise that can qualify which is a
rather sad criterium. Now I don't want
to upset anyone here this evening and I
don't want to hurt anyone's feelings but
the fact of the matter is that this
power is so clearly identified that I
myself who was part of that power had to
resign from that power and leave it. I
was affected myself. I was very shocked
when I found this out and it actually
physically made me sick when I
discovered this.
So, who is he? He arises out of the
fourth beast. He arises among the 10
horns. After the 10 horns, he's
different from the others. When the last
wave of barbarian invasions had spent
its force, the faiths of Europe had been
transformed. Independent Germanic
kingdoms had been established on the
ruins of the Roman Empire. That's church
history, page 175.
Out of the ruins of the Roman Empire,
there gradually arose a new order of
states whose central point was the papal
sea. Therefore, inevitably resulted a
position not only new but very different
from the former, the church and
churches, page 42 and 43. This is a
Roman Catholic source
saying that here was a different
situation
to what there was before.
There are two theories on the antichrist
in the world today that are being taught
by every single church in the world
almost.
The one is
River Ribera and the other one is
Alcaza's policy. Now what did they
teach?
They taught
preterism and futurism. Pretterism
teaches that the antichrist came in the
past in the time of the Greeks. Futurism
teaches that he'll come in the future
after the Christian church has been
taken away. And both of these doctrines
are not biblical because both of them
violate Daniel chapter 7, Daniel chapter
8, the whole book of Revelation. They
violate every single biblical principle.
All of them. And who were Ribera and who
was Alcaza?
Well, the two of them were Jesuits.
So these are doctrines set into the
world after the reformation by the Roman
church itself to take away the emphasis
from the papacy and put them in two
different directions. Historian CC
Echot. When the Roman Empire had
disintegrated and its place had been
taken by a number of rude, barbarous
kingdoms, the Roman Catholic Church not
only became independent of the state in
religious affairs, but dominated secular
affairs as well, the papacy and world
affairs, page one. So here was a horn, a
kingdom that became more stout than the
others. It dominated them. It qualifies.
Historian Thomas Hobb says, "If a man
consider the origin of the great
ecclesiastical dominion, he will easily
perceive that the papacy is none other
than the ghost of the deceased Roman
Empire sitting crowned upon the grave
thereof."
Okay, so Rome is not really gone. It's
called the Roman Catholic Church, isn't
it? So Rome is not really gone at all.
Leviatan page 457.
He shall be different from the first. We
saw that Rome says, "Yes, we're
different because now it is a religious
power that wields political clout,
more stout than his fellows." Daniel
7:20. He would be mightier than the
other kings. Did the kings of Europe bow
down to the papacy? Yes. Sometimes yes,
sometimes no. If no, eventually they
were subjugated and did bow down.
Eventually they did have to come like
Frederick of Germany and stand barefoot
in the snow waiting for a reprieve to
get his kingdom back.
The most holy councils volume 13 Rome
says we define that the holy apostolic
sea and the Roman pontiff holds the
primacy over how much of the world? The
whole world. That's interesting.
The vicor of the incarnate son of God,
anointed high priest and supreme
temporal ruler, the pope sat in his
tribunal impartially to judge between
nation and nation, people and prince,
sovereign and subject. Henry Connell
Manning, temporal power of the vicor of
Jesus Christ. So did they say that they
were in control of all the other
kingdoms? Yes or no? Yes, they claim so
themselves.
Keys of this blood. Pope John Paul 2
versus Russia and the West for control
of the new world order. Malachi Martin,
pontipical professor at the Gregorian
University in Rome itself. He's saying
it, not me.
Uprooted three kingdoms. Then I would
know the truth of the fourth beast,
which was diverse from all the others,
and of the 10 horns that were in his
head, and of the other which came up and
before whom three fell. Daniel 7:19 and
20. Yes, Rome claims that the three were
uprooted because they were Aryan. They
didn't believe that Christ was God,
which is one of the teachings of Rome.
But we will see that that is just an
exoteric teaching of Rome. There is
another teaching of Rome which is called
esoteric which is a hidden teaching
which says something completely
different but that'll take another
lecture. It has eyes like a man, and it
spoke great words against the most high.
Here's a system that sets itself up
above God, and will speak against the
most high, and it will wear out the
saints.
There was given him a mouth speaking
great things and blasphemy, says verse
five, blasphemy. So, what is blasphemy?
And it was given unto him to make war
with the saints and to overcome them.
Did the Roman church do this?
Absolutely. Daniel 7:25, you shall speak
great words against the most high. Shall
wear out the saints of the most high.
Think to change times and laws. Of
course, you can't change God's laws.
It's just the power that thinks it can.
And they shall be given into his hand
until a time, times, and the dividing of
times. We'll have to look at those texts
in detail. Let's first look at the
biblical definition of blasphemy and see
whether Rome qualifies.
Well, we find it in John chapter 10
verse 30 and 33. I and the father are
one, says Jesus. Jesus says he's God.
The Jews answered him saying, "We do not
stone you for a good work, but for
blasphemy,
and because you being a man, make
yourself God." So the one definition in
the Bible of blasphemy is if someone
says that he's God. Well, there are many
blasphemas in the world today. But uh
that's the one definition. The other
definition we find in Luke where it
says, "And seeing their faith, he said
to the man, your sins are forgiven you."
And the scribes and the Pharisees began
to reason saying, "Who is this who
speaks blasphemy? Who can forgive sins
except God alone?" So there are two
biblical definitions of blasphemy. The
one is if you say that you are God and
the other one is if you say that you can
forgive sins.
Well, what does the Rome say? Here's the
Catholic Encyclopedia, volume 12,
article on the Pope. It says, "This
judicial authority will even include the
power to pardon sin." So Rome says it
can forgive sins. The Catholic priest
page 78 says, "Seek where you will
through heaven and earth, and you will
find one created being who can forgive
the sinner, who can free him from the
chains of hell. That extraordinary being
is the priest, the Roman Catholic
priest."
Interesting. The outer priest forever,
says the ordaining bishop. He's no
longer a man, a sinful child of Adam,
but an altar Christos, another Christ.
That's interesting.
Another Christ in the place of Jesus
Christ. In the place of in Greek is anti
Christos,
Antichrist, in the place of forever a
priest of the most high with power over
the Almighty. Now that's heavy to say
that you have more power than God. The
Pope is not only the representative of
Jesus Christ, but he is Jesus Christ
himself hidden under the veil of flesh.
The Catholic National July 1895.
So Rome has always claimed that she is
in the position of God.
God himself is obliged to abide by the
judgment of his priests and either not
to pardon or to pardon according as they
the priests refuse or give absolution.
The sentence of the priest precedes and
God subscribes to it. Dignities and
duties of the priest volume 12 page 27.
Wow. So the Catholic Church says who is
saved and who is lost and God hasn't got
a hope. He has to abide by their
judgment. And if they say no, God can't
say yes. So who's mightier? They or God?
They are. Is this blasphemy? Yes or no?
This is blasphemy of the highest order.
Cardinal Bellamine says, "All names
which in scripture are applied to Christ
by virtue of which it is established
that he's over the church. All the same
names are applied to the pope."
That means he assumes the place of God.
So he qualifies on that count given in
Rome from our palace the 10th of
February 1817
the 15th jurisdiction of the most holy
pontiff andantan father in Christ and
our lord our god the pope Leo I 12th
so the pope had himself crowned as god
we hold upon this earth the place of god
almighty the great ecclesiastical
letters of pope Leo did you know that
when the papacy today writes an
encyclical.
It always signs the encyclical Pope John
Paul 2 in other words does this given by
us capital letter in our capital letter
pontificates.
Interesting because God says let us make
man in
our image capitals. So the papacy takes
the prerogative and to this day by their
writing they claim to have and be the
power of God.
So Rome qualifies the most high council.
We define that the holy apostolic sea
and the Roman pontiff hold the primacy
over the whole world. Now this power
would eventually take control of the
whole world. Does Rome really control
the world? That's ludicrous.
Do you really believe that? Think it's
possible?
Well, we're going to have a lecture
tomorrow on secret societies.
I wouldn't miss it if I were you.
Thomas Akinus wrote secular power. This
is the great Catholic philosopher that
is quoted by John Paul 2 more than any
other philosopher of the Roman Catholic
Church. He he writes secular power is
subject to the spiritual power as the
body is subject to the soul and
therefore it is not a usurpation of
authority if the spiritual prelate
interfere in temporal things concerning
those matters in which the secular power
is subject to him.
So everybody is subject to Rome. The
council of Trent declared all temporal
power is his. The dominion, the
jurisdiction and the government of the
whole earth is his by divine right. All
rulers of the earth are his subject and
must submit to him.
That was the council of Trent.
That's the one that ended
the attack of the reformation.
Here we have
a lady who said uh Jesus said, "I am the
good shepherd." And this lady said,
"It's like being with God." When she saw
John Paul 2,
did she wear out the saints?
It was given him to make war with the
saints and to overcome them. Well,
again, Thomas Ainus said that convicted
heretics should be put to death just as
surely as other criminals. The Catholic
Church is a respector of conscience and
of liberty. Nevertheless, when
confronted with heresy, she has resource
to force to corporal punishment to
torture. She lit in Italy the funeral
piles of the Inquisition. Catholic
professor Alfred Budat the Catholic
Church Renaissance Protestantism. Yes,
she admits it. Here is the KZA del Yeu
which is the seat of the Jesuits. Here
is the Jesuit oath that is made which
basically says that they can get rid of
any heretical king in the entire world.
any commonwealth of governments that
does not want to subject itself to the
papacy and anybody who does not submit
to the authority of the Roman pontiff
can be safely destroyed. So the church
ruled as the woman ruling over kings.
That is how she depicted herself
throughout history. The Inquisition.
Well, the Inquisition tells us that she
wore out the saints, the Tower of
London, the Hague in the Netherlands.
What is the definition of heresy?
Greek heresis, choice, deciding for
oneself what one shall believe and
practice. That's heresy. So, who must
decide for you?
Rome must decide for you what you must
believe. And if you do not fall in line
with this, well then you must be
eliminated. You must be eradicated.
Well, we are heading for some thunderous
times in the world that we live in
today. These are some of the instruments
of torture that they used. These were
terrible things. These tongs over here
were opened up and they were could close
like two little buckets making a little
ball. They would put hot coals in there
and then sort you out that way.
They would uh put these shackles around
you. These were put around the feet.
Notice the pins on the inside. They
would go right into the bone. They were
so wicked. This one over here went
around the neck and then they would
tighten this screw and of course it
would push right here into your Adam's
apple. And in fact, General Franco
in the 1970s in Spain still used that
instrument of torture. Can you believe
that?
How primitive can you get? And the
stocks and the thumb screws and this
terrible thing over here where they
would hoist you upside down with your
hands behind your back and lift you up
this way high above and hang you from
the ceiling and then they'd attach this
ball on a high shelf, this heavy stone
to your feet, roll it down and rip your
arms right up. That was pretty mean the
way they did. Those are are
representations of the PS, the stakes of
the Inquisition and they killed
literally millions and millions of
people. There's the famous Hugeno
monument in Africa where the French
hugenos escaped and uh after the great
massacre where the hugenos were
massacred, Bartholomew massacre and they
depicted themselves as a woman, a church
escaping with a Bible in her hand and
the chains of Rome torn loose. Well, I
have news for you. This woman is once
again chained and every other woman on
the planet talking of churches is once
again chained.
Changes times and laws.
Think to change times and laws. Daniel
7:25.
Does the pope claim that he changed
God's law? Absolutely. Decatal transl.
The pope has power to change times, to
abregate laws, and to dispense with all
things even the precepts of Christ.
That's arrogance of the highest order.
So they say that they can change these
things. Did the papacy change the times?
Certainly did. What calendar are we
keeping in the world today? Who knows?
We're keeping the Gregorian calendar.
Who was Gregory?
He was a pope. And were the times
changed? Yes. On the authority of whom?
Of the Jesuit astronomers. What did they
change? They changed Easter. They
brought the Easter feasts to bring them
in line with the feast of Easter. They
even called it that, Easter. Easter
feast. And so whereas the pash was
celebrated according to the new moon and
the Passover could take place on any day
of the week depending on when the new
moon was cited. So the papacy changed it
and followed the symbolism of the
Sadducees who were trained in Alexandria
in occult teaching and moved it in line
with the feast of Ishta. And now Easter
falls only on a Sunday and never
coincides with the Passover. It is
possible with the calendar that they
have that at some stage in history it
can actually coincide with the Passover.
And what does the papacy then decree? If
there happens to be a lining up of the
Passover with the feast of Easter, then
the papacy shifts Easter one week. said
it'll still fall on the Sunday. So she
changed the times and the feasts
definitely
also since these times we are
celebrating the day from midnight to
midnight and not from sunset to sunset.
And then did she abregate the laws and
dispense with the things and the
precepts of Christ? The pope can modify
divine law prompt biblote who gives you
the right Mr. Pope to change the law of
God.
the ten commandments as originally given
by God on the first tablet. You shall
have no other gods before me. Then there
is this big commandment that you shall
not bow down to idols. And then you may
not take the name of the Lord your vain.
The Sabbath commandment
the is very prominent. And then you have
the commandments
dictating the relationship between man
and man. Honor your father and your
mother. shalt not kill, adultery, uh
theft, um thou shalt not bring false
witness and covetousness. Those are the
commandments as they are in the Bible.
If you take the Catholic catechism,
you'll see that the second commandment
has been removed. You shall not have
other gods shall not he shall be able to
change laws. Of course, he says there
will I am the Lord of God. You shall
have no strange gods before me. Thou
shalt not take the name of the Lord thy
God in vain. So the second commandment
is gone. This one has moved one up.
Remember to keep holy the Sabbath day.
But what have they done to that? We'll
see about that in a moment. And so they
only have nine commandments. And to get
10, they take the commandment on
coveting and split it into two. Thou
shalt not coveret thy neighbor's wife
and thou shalt not coveret thy neighbors
goods. Very fascinating. Remember that
this one over here says, "Thou shalt not
coveret thy neighbor's house. Thou shalt
not coveret thy neighbor's wife." So
they turn it round. Isn't that
fascinating? They even have the goal to
turn it round as if they had the right
to do that. The Catholic Encyclopedia
says the church after changing the day
of rest from the Jewish Sabbath or the
seventh day of the week to the first
made the third commandment referred to
Sunday because the second one was gone
now as the day to be kept holy as the
Lord's day. Catholic encyclopedia. So
they changed the times. Even the day of
worship which was the seventh day was
shifted to the first day of the week.
Matthew 5:17 says, "Think not that I
came to destroy the law and the
prophets. I came not to destroy, but to
fulfill, to live them out."
Here's the Converts Catechism of the
Catholic Doctrine, page 50. And it says,
"Question, which is the Sabbath day?"
Answer: Saturday is the Sabbath day.
Catholic Church is well aware of it.
They know it. Question, why do we
observe Sunday instead of Saturday?
answer. We observe Sunday instead of
Saturday because the Catholic Church in
the council of Laua transferred the
somnity from the Saturday to the Sunday.
So did she change times and laws? Yes or
no? Yes, she did. Times, times, and half
a time. What does that refer to? The
saints will be handed over to him for a
time, times, and half a time. If you
have a modern Bible, it'll say three and
a half years. Now, prophetic years are
different to normal years. A year in a
prophetic sense had 360 days because the
Hebrew year had 360 days. So, 360 two
times, 720, half a time, half a year,
180. Add them all up, that would give
you 1,260
prophetic days.
Now that becomes 1,260
literal years. Let's just sort this out.
With the conquest of Rome by Bellisarius
commences the history of the middle
ages. So when Rome was conquered and the
Ostrogoths were removed, the history of
the middle ages started. Philip Shape
says Vigulus ascended the papal chair
538 AD under the military protection of
Belisarius.
So when did the little horn power assume
its authority? The answer is 538 AD
because the last of the little horns or
of the horn powers that kept him back
were the Ostrogoths. They were removed
in 538 AD and Vigilus ascends the papal
chair. So the dominance of Rome begins.
Another shall arise after them. The 10
kingdoms established AD 476.
After them AD 538 paperal rule commences
according to a decree which was issued
by Justinian emperor of Rome who said
that the pope will be the corrector of
heretics and the ruler of all the
churches. Now 538
if you add 1,260
you come to 1,798.
1798.
What happened in 1798?
Bertier entered Rome on the 10th of
February 1798 and proclaimed a republic.
Half of Europe thought Napoleon's veto
would be obeyed and that with the pope
the papacy was dead. So exactly
according to prophetic time and the
Bible tells us to take a day for a year.
Exactly according to that time when the
clock struck 1798
the temporal power of the papacy was
halted for a while. So 1,260ear
time prophecy. 476 AD the 10 kingdoms
are established. 538 AD the bishop
officially recognized as the ruler of
all the churches.
1,260
years of time prophecy brings us to 1798
fulfilled. His domain and dominion ended
1,260
years.
It was based on 1,260
days, which is the same as three and a
half prophetic years, but it's also the
same as 42 months. 42 * 30, that was the
biblical month. 42 * 30 is also 1,260.
Now in Revelation 12 verse 6 we read
1,23
score days. That's 1,260
days. In Revelation 12:14 a time, times
and half a time. See how Revelation
picks up the theme of this power and
brings it into the heart of Revelation.
Here they all are. Daniel 7:25, time,
times, and the dividing of time
referring to this power. Daniel 12:7,
time, times and a half. Revelation 11:2,
42 months. Revelation 11:3, 1260 days.
Revelation 12:6, 1260 days. Revelation
12:14, time, times, and half a time.
Revelation 13 540, and two months. All
of these referring to the same power.
Notice how many there are. 1 2 3 four
five six seven. The Bible is fantastic.
What's it telling us? That this power
would set itself up as another god
because seven is the number of God and
it would assume all these
characteristics. And I saw one of his
heads as it were wounded to death.
And his deadly wound was healed. Rome
receives a wound in the form of the
little horn power, but it's going to be
healed. And all the world wandered after
the beast. Revelation 13:3. So the same
power that ruled over the saints for
1,260 days receives a mortal wound 1798
will rise again and the whole world will
be subject to it. That's what the Bible
says.
And power was given him over all
kindreds and tongues and nations. Does
that include the United States? Does
that include my country? Yes, it does.
Ronald Reagan and the papacy made a holy
alliance. That's a fascinating story.
We'll have to go into that into a little
bit more detail. And so even the mighty
United States subjected itself to this
power. Here we have a signal picture
between Gorbachof and the papacy. This
is the mighty Soviet Union at that stage
greeting and acknowledging this power.
It is a big idea in new world order
where diverse nations are drawn together
in a common cause. Only the United
States has both the moral standing and
the means to back it up.
At the second Vatican Council, this was
in 1962 document. It states, "It is our
duty therefore to strain every muscle in
working for the time when all war will
be completely outlawed by international
consent." This is the second Vatican
council.
This goal undoubtedly requires the
establishment of a universal public
authority acknowledged as such by all
and endowed with the power to safeguard
on behalf of all security, regard for
justice and respect for rights.
Pope Paul V 6 wrote in the section
entitled towards effective world
authority. He wrote, "This international
collaboration on a worldwide scale
requires institutions that will prepare,
coordinate, direct it until finally
there is established an order of justice
which is universally recognized. who
does not see the necessity of thus
establishing progressively a world
authority capable of acting effectively
in judicial and political sectors.
Fascinating stuff.
And who was crowned ruler of the whole
world?
This man himself.
Fascinating.
John Paul superstar
mre
the united Europe what is the world to
say about this why has the parliament of
Europe got this construction
very interesting construction we'll give
a whole lecture on this interesting
situation in Europe and what it means
what did uh George W Bush say about this
power March 22 he said, "The best way to
honor Pope John Paul 2, truly one of the
great men, is to take his teachings
seriously, is to listen to his words and
put his words and teachings into action
here in America. This is a challenge we
must accept."
So, who is subject to who here?
Who is subject to who?
In 1991, the Pope called for a new world
order. Well, what was his New Year's
speech about this year?
He had only one message and he said,
"It's time to establish the world
authority right now." That was his
request.
He visited the United Nations. He spoke
on behalf of all the religions in the
entire world. Now please note that that
includes Buddhism and Hinduism and
Shintuism and Zoroastiism
and Protestantism and Catholicism and
the whole shooting match.
Is there an agenda?
And Garbachov said,
"We must
help John Paul too because he is right
in his request for a new world order,"
said Gorbachov when the Pope spoke at
the United Nations at its 50th
celebration.
All right. Do you think it is possible
that Rome could be this power? That the
Vatican could be this power. But surely
the Vatican looks like a noble Christian
power
trying to set the right values into the
world. Doesn't it look like that?
Remember the Bible says man of pition.
Judas looked like one of them, but he
betrayed Jesus with a kiss. Here is a
power that looks like one of them, but
could just betray it with a kiss. We'll
have to go into the secrets of the
secret societies to find out what this
is all about. What did the reformers
teach on this power? Many of the great
Christians of the reformation and
post-reformation times shared this view
of prophetic truth and identified
antichrist with a Roman papacy. Among
the adherence of this interpretation
were the Valdenzis, the Husidites, White
Cliff, Luther, Calvin, Swingley,
Meankton, the Baptist theologian, John
Gil, the Marts, Cranmer, Tindel,
Latimer, Ridley, all of them said Rome
was the antichrist. Let's see what
Martin Luther said. Luther said, I know
that the pope is antichrist and that his
seat is that of Satan himself.
The papacy is a general chased by
command of the Roman pontiff for the
purpose of running down and destroying
souls. That's pretty straight talk. He
didn't mince words in those days. What
did John Calvin say? He said, "We
recall, we call the Roman pontiff
Antichrist." Interesting. What did John
Wesley say? He said, "He is in the
emphatic sense the man of sin as he
increases all manner of sin above
measure." That's what the reformers
said. What did John Nox say? He said
that the pope should be recognized as
the very antichrist.
Well, the reformers didn't want anyone
to forget.
So in Nirbach, which was the seat of
Protestantism
on the town hall, they had this
sculpture presented over the two doors.
And if you look over here, you'll find
something interesting. you'll find the
prophecy we dealt with tonight. On the
one side, you have a lion with eagle's
wings and they have a ruler next to him
and they tell us who he is. It is
Nebuchadnezzar.
So, who did the reformers say the lions
with eagle wings stood for?
Babylon. If we go to the other side, you
have a bear with three ribs in his
mouth. And they put a king next to him,
a mighty king, to tell us who they
believed it represented. And who was it?
This is Cyrus the Great.
So hereby they are saying it was the Mes
and the Persians. The reformers didn't
mince words. They put it in stone.
Didn't go and see it today. If you go to
the other side, you'll see the other
door. That's what it looks like. Let's
go a little bit closer. There is a
leopard beast with four heads. And who
do they put next to it to say who they
believed it was? That's Alexander the
Great. So, they identified it with
Greece. And on the other side is a
terrible beast with 10 horns. And they
have a mighty emperor there. And who is
he? Is Julius Caesar. So, who did they
say it was? They said it was wrong.
And then over here they have this
strange little structure coming up
amongst them and it has the face of a
man and it has this strange little
crown. They made no bones as to who it
was. They said it was Rome. Who teaches
that today still?
Nobody.
Nobody teaches it anymore. Do the
Christian churches teach it? No, they
don't. In fact, they have all joined the
ecumenical movement which says let's
again accept Rome as our spiritual
leader.
All the Christian denominations
are part of their ecmenical movement and
all of them are saying
put the chains back on.
Rather sad.
Let not anyone deceive you by any means,
for that day shall not come unless the
first comes of falling away. And the man
of sin shall be revealed, the son of
pition, who opposes and exalts himself
over all that is called God, all that is
worshiped, so that he sits as God in the
temple of God, setting himself forth,
that he is God. Does this make sense?
Now, it certainly does. If it were
possible, they shall deceive the very
elect.
The garb of Christianity is so perfect
that we do not see the core of occultism
behind it. Who really runs the show
there? Who is behind it? What power is
yielded in Rome? Who is the black pope?
Who is Peta Hunts Kulvinbach at the
moment? Who is that? What is his role in
the world? Would you like to know?
So we see he shall devour the whole
earth. That means this web of intrigue
must spread across the whole world and
he will continue to the end. He's here
right now but his dominion will be taken
away at the end of time. Now I am not
saying that any Roman Catholic who is
not aware of any of this which is in the
Bible is Antichrist. I'm talking about a
system here. This is a system. There are
many many fine Roman Catholics in the
Roman Catholic Church who worship God
according to the best knowledge and
according to the conscience that they
have. And God takes the knowledge that
they have and judges according to the
knowledge that they have. I'm talking
about a system that has deceived even
its own members and that sets itself up
above God. The Bible says the judgment
shall sit and they shall take away his
rulership to cut off and to destroy
until the end. And the kingdom and the
rulership will belong to who? Will
belong to God's people. For the son of
man is going to come in his father's
glory with his angels. And then he will
reward each person according to what he
has done. And the greatness of the
kingdoms under all the heavens, says
Daniel, shall be given to the people of
the saints of the most high, whose
kingdom is an everlasting kingdom, and
all kingdoms shall serve and obey him.
God is going to make an end of all
things very soon. And to find out what
the intrigue behind the intrigues are, I
invite you to come to the next lectures.
Even if you were upset tonight,
it's very important that you come to the
next lectures because this whole plan
will be unfolded as we go into the book
of Revelation. May the Lord be with you
and help you and guide you.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Baby.
Heat. Heat.
Oh,
hey.
[music]
Hey
everybody.